>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> David Plylar: We are
so happy to have you here.
You are in for a real
treat today with some music
that you are not going to hear
that often, especially live.
My name is David Plylar, I
am with the concert office.
The Library of Congress and it's
my distinct pleasure to be here
with Maestro Sandro Ivo Bartoli
who will be giving us a program
that largely focuses on Bach but
through the lenses of [foreign name]
who is, we are celebrating
his 150th birthday this year.
So, I was thinking
maybe we could start
with just maybe you
could say a few words
about this program
and how it came about.
>> Sandro Ivo Bartoli:
Oh absolutely.
Can you hear me?
[inaudible] First of all, let
me say forgive me for the delay
but after all I am Italian.
I have to be a little late.
[laughter] It would
not be in character.
The program well in my
opinion I hope in a couple
of hours you will agree with
me it's a beautiful program.
It's in a way it's a pianist dream
because [foreign name] was one
of the greatest authors
of piano music.
Pretty much everything that
he did you can sense a joy
of playing the piano.
His music is written magnificently
for our instrument and a lot
of the inspiration as some
people say come from Poppa Bach
who was probably the greatest
composer of the entire history
of music and beyond, really.
We have a little bit of an intrusion
in the second half of [inaudible].
Who happens to be again another one
of my favorite composers
for many reasons.
But one of the many reasons is that
his music is very much nefarious.
It encompasses a huge range
of emotions and as a composer
that I admire very much but
he is not very well known,
his name is [foreign name].
He used to say that without
the emotion there is nothing
and certainly this will not
be the case this afternoon.
>> David Plylar: Well,
this so the opening work
on the program is maybe one of
Busoni's most performed pieces
and it's a transcription of a
solo violin work and there's,
it's notable I think
it's good to mention that
but had I not mentioned it and
then had you had never heard it
by chance you might
not have any idea
that it originated as
a solo violin work.
It seems like it fits really
naturally as a piano piece
in the way that he adapted it.
>> Sandro Ivo Bartoli:
Well, Busoni was a bit
of a [inaudible] in distinct.
I mean that fact that he
turned between the 19th
and the 20th century he became
so popular as a transcriber
that you know he began to actually
bother people because he was
so imaginative in his way of writing
for the piano that he did a lot
of transcription for the organ
works of Bach and those also
in his version become so
idiomatic for our instrument
that you know unless you know
the region you wouldn't guess
that the original was
written for other instrument.
Which I believe is a testament to
his musical and pianistic genius.
Absolutely.
>> David Plylar: No, I
agree and one of the things
that I think is good to listen for.
How many just by curiosity
how many are you familiar
with the original [foreign
name] for solo violin?
It's worth checking out after you
are done with this because one
of the things that you'll
find is there's a repeating,
basically a base line in
repeating tune that you'll hear
and Busoni clarifies it throughout
the entire piece and it's one
of the ways that he
contributes to it in addition
to just having incredibly
imaginative writing.
>> Sandro Ivo Bartoli:
Well, it's to me,
the first time I heard the [foreign
name] I was a young kid really
and it was played by this
person who became my mentor.
A pianist named [foreign name]
and the impression he gave me was
like an old man telling a story to
a younger person and that's perhaps
because of this reoccurring theme on
the ground base which is fantastic.
But then also you know of course I
wanted to learn the [foreign name]
and then I became friends with
[foreign name] of the story
but I learned of the origin
of the [foreign name]
from Spain apparently.
And it was an erotic dance so I
fell in love with it immediately.
Absolutely.
All over again.
[laughter]
>> David Plylar: [laughter] I am
not sure how to follow that up
but you are going to enjoy it a lot.
The second piece in the program is
this wonderful kind of amalgamation
of Busoni's thought with Bach and
it's basically an interaction.
It's like you are watching a meeting
of minds between Busoni and Bach
through the, using the art of
fugue as kind of the focal point.
What can you say about that piece?
I mean there's so much that
you can say about it but to you
as a pianist especially how do
approach this kind of a work?
That's part transcription
part composition part lots
of other stuff?
>> Sandro Ivo Bartoli: Well,
I devoted a lot of my time
to the study of Busoni's music
and his life of course I had
to play the fantasy of [inaudible].
His most important
work for solo piano.
The underline theme is that
it is the completion of Bach
and finished work the art of fugue.
Bach left what was essentially
a quadruple feud unfinished
after the entrance
of the third subject.
Which is his own name.
And very many people in the 1800's
suggested possible conclusion
but nobody really did
anything with it.
But Busoni actually did
complete the quadruple fugue.
You must bear in mind that
Senor Busoni was a rather,
had a very large personality.
He was not content with
completing the fugue.
I mean he wrote the huge preludes
to this quadruple fugue then
there's a little interned or a set
of variations on the
themes from the fugue.
[foreign names] The work grew
to rather monumental proportions
but I think there are two elements
to the fantasy of [foreign name]
that they are fundamental.
The first is that Busoni said it
was a piece compiled for the piano.
So, it's not really a concert piece
in the accepted sense of the word.
And the second and perhaps most
important is not only a meeting
of two minds which through
Bach and Senor Busoni
but there too is a
meeting of two times.
Because he manages in this piece to
embroider the original Bach material
into an early 20th century idiom.
And then towards the
middle of the composition,
Bach is of course left behind and
it becomes Busoni at times it sounds
like [foreign name] on acid and
we went also with the harmonies,
you know, it went really crazy.
But it's part of the beauty of
this very, very important piece.
I mean none other than Dr.
Albert Schweitzer who was
to win the Nobel Prize for Peace
but in his own right was a great
musicologist and scholar of Bach.
He admired very much this work that
Busoni had done and he proclaimed
that Busoni found the solution to
the riddle of Bach's last fugue.
It's no mean fete.
>> David Plylar: I should mention
that after this talk before the
concert we have a first addition
of the Art of Fugue from
actually sadly from 1800.
But we have that out and we
have that open to a place
where the third fugue subject
enters and that's the BACH.
So, B flat, A, C, B natural
and that places a major role
in the full piece as you can see.
But there's actually a
completion to this one
that you should take a look at.
But it's shortened and not quite
as imaginative as Busoni's.
[laughter] After this at that
point we will take a break
for intermission but then
we are going to look at Bach
through a different lens
and this is we actually are,
we programmed a piece that's
based in a Bach cantata movement
of the [foreign name] and there's
several pieces you may be familiar
with the variations
on a motive from this.
But this is actually a prelude
that listed composed for the piano.
The variations was originally
kind of conceived as an organ work
but the prelude is a piano work
that the Library of Congress has
and we have it on display,
the manuscript for that.
But what do you think of
performing that piece?
What has that been like?
I think this is a new
piece for you in terms of.
>> Sandro Ivo Bartoli: Yes.
Yes, and I should thank you guys for
asking me to do it because you know
of course like most
pianists in the early '90's
when Mr. Horovitz last cd came out.
He had recorded this piece
which I didn't know at the time
and oh my God it is beautiful.
I am going to learn it, you know.
And then of course you always think
well Horovitz is playing is what is
little stupid me going to do
you know learning this piece.
Then of course Mr. Horovitz suddenly
died and you know at various time
in my life I thought of well
I should learn the Prelude
such a beautiful piece
but somehow never managed,
mustered the courage to do it.
There was always something
else to do.
And I am Italian after all.
So, I never learned it and then when
David mentioned that the Library
of Congress had acquired
the manuscript well
of course there was no
escape at the point.
There was of course an adventure
because it is again
the work of a genius.
It takes six or seven notes
from the base of this cantata
and then the Prelude is a very
short six or seven minutes of music
but it's 20 odd variations on
this tiny little melodic cell.
And one more beautiful
than the other.
It's also very tragic piece.
It's very pensive, very.
I mean the title means
size, tears, sorrow,
fear and so it's a very
uplifting kind of thing to start.
[laughter]
>> David Plylar: But it also it's
you know I think we probably,
I should say that we thought
of this at the very beginning
but it's a nice, it's
almost like a mirror.
Rather the [foreign name] in terms
of having another structure that's
similar but just more compacted.
>> Sandro Ivo Bartoli:
Much more coercive.
And I think this is getting a
little bit too technical maybe
but in this piece, there's a passage
where a list is actually write
like Bach, it's just
a two voice, you know.
Your right hand is
playing one note at a time,
the left-hand mirrors
this one note at a time.
Very unusual for list.
But there's only four or five bars.
It could easily Bach except
perhaps for the harmony.
Which is also something that
Busoni does in the Fantasy
of [foreign name] when he was
writing the [foreign name] minute
excerpt from which it could
have been written by Bach.
It very much is the meeting of
two minds and also going back
to the beginning except now we are
at the beginning of the second half.
>> David Plylar: The, one thing
that I wanted to bring up is
that you recently recorded a CD that
was focused on the [foreign name]
and this is part of
what we, excuse me,
this is part of what the
next two works are from that.
Well, not from that disc but were
part of that collection of works
and maybe you could
tell us a bit about that
because while it's a
departure from the Bach theme,
there is still this religious
connotation that comes through.
Well, it is not generally known
but you know List at 16 wanted
to become a Catholic Priest.
He was prevented by his mother
and we should be thankful
to his mother I think because
the gain is prosperity.
But he had this very
romantic, you know, life.
When he was bored reading
a biography, a list.
He was the first well one of
the first two music superstars.
The other was Paganini.
But when he was in his 50's,
two of this three children died
in the space of three years
and understandably he had a very
profound crisis and after a series
of again adventures events.
He took the orders of
the Franciscan order.
He became a Franciscan monk moved
to Rome to a little monastery
in the outskirts of Rome.
And began writing religious
music he had been writing
for quite a few years.
But at the point he began writing
music dedicated to his patron Saints
for St. Francis of [foreign
name] and St. Francis of power.
The pieces that they play today
are perhaps the most famous
of this sphere of the Francesca
music of List and rightly so.
I mean they are religious pieces
but they are very comfortable
in the concert also.
I am very grateful to
Maestro List actually
because with the [foreign
name] which stayed
for about ten years earlier.
It was trying actively to bridge
the gap between the church
and the concert and the theatre.
Very successfully in my opinion.
And before coming here
to America I was invited
to play the [foreign name] which is
the world's oldest music festival.
But it's devoted to sacred music.
So, they very rarely
have pianists play there
but fortunately I had this music
France List, Francesca music
so I was able to take part
in this very unusual event
and you know I wanted to bring a
little part of it over to America.
The American dream [inaudible].
>> Davis Plylar: Wow.
You know one thing I should
mention about these pieces
and also other pieces that are
on that disc that you have is
that they are also, he has
this, there are also transcript,
these ones originated
as piano pieces.
But right afterwards he made
versions for orchestra as well.
That were I think not
recorded for another century.
Or not played for another
century or so later
but there's this interesting
relationship
between List transcription
of his own works and trying
to give them different
voices as well
as just having these
original works for solo piano.
>> Sandro Ivo Bartoli:
Well, I think he knew
that he had done something
very good with it two legends.
He also had quite a
nice endorsement.
He got a visit from the Pope
in this little monastery
and he played the first legend,
St. Francis preaching to the birds.
At least the Pope suggested at
least basically concentrated
on earthly harmonies in
preparation for the timeless ones.
So, effectively encouraged
him to go on in the same way.
I would have done that.
>> David Plylar: [laughter]
Yes that's, and we should say
that there are a lot of bird
sounds in this, in that first one.
>> Sandro Ivo Bartoli: I am sorry
I have used this word already two
or three times and maybe I
am affectionate but you know,
when you go and play with
genius all things up.
Many people, many composers have
tried to mimic the song of birds
in music but to [foreign names]
there's a very famous piece,
Fresco Baldi wrote [foreign name].
Right up to the 20th century when
Mr. [foreign name] actually went
to the woods, recorded it
on tape, the song of birds.
And then notated it down.
List is the only one who
actually made correct impression
of what a bunch of little
birds sounds like you hear.
>> David Plylar: And
he wasn't limited
to 140 characters for
his tweets but.
[laughter] So, moving passed
on to the final work just
to tie it together to,
back to Busoni and to Bach.
This is a piece that I
feel is really underheard
and not underappreciated for sure.
It started off as an organ
work, it's a fantasy in fugue
on the [foreign name] which
was a part of a Miarbere Opera
that had just come out in 1849
la Parfet and List made a series
of three illustrations that came out
first and then he really got stuck
on this theme and decided to make
this giant structure for organ
that is where we hear a fantasy,
a large fantasy, a central kind
of [foreign name], quiet
very beautiful section.
Followed by a magnificent fugue
that is based on the crowd tune
and then Busoni recognized
the greatness of this piece
and took his expertise in
transcription and brang it
to the world of piano music.
And have you performed this much?
Does it get asked for?
>> Sandro Ivo Bartoli: I
performed it a few times.
I recorded it a few years ago.
But it's such a, again a huge piece.
I think it's about
a half an hour long.
You don't get that many
chances putting it [inaudible].
You know, fortunately also in
order to program half an hour takes
up maybe, it's usually it's
about the third of the length
of piano recital and
promoted producers they say
in England they want to
put bombs in the seats.
They need to sell tickets
and so they don't
like if you play this long
pieces that nobody knows.
When they hear it then usually they
like it because it is a masterpiece.
But I don't get to
play it all the time.
I am delighted I can do it today.
>> David Plylar: No, I am really
pleased especially it ties
in so well because one of the
things that is also really great
about Busoni that most people don't
know about him is that he was also
or I should say many people don't
know maybe you all know this.
Is that he was also a good
explainer of what he was doing.
So, he would write about his
processes of transcription
and really elucidate it so
that one could follow that.
One could learn from
that and do it oneself.
Maybe not to the level of a Busoni
but you can see him applying this
school of thought that he took
to the Bach organ works, applying it
to the later List work in this case.
And it's just a fascinating
thing to study I think.
>> Sandro Ivo Bartoli:
Well, it's also a lesson,
a huge lesson in piano
playing and piano writing.
The piece is magnificent.
It ought to rank among the
best piano writing ever.
The effect that Senior Busoni
to recreate the piano
for, I mean you hear it.
It's a monument to the art of
playing the piano or the craft
of playing the piano rather.
It is not very classy of me to say
this but it is very tricky to play
so maybe that's part of the
reason why it is very long.
It's not very well known.
And you need to invest a
lot of time in learning it.
Because really it only stretches
the limit of what pianist can do.
I think Alan Walker
called it a pinnacle
in 20th century [inaudible] Got
the century wrong unfortunately.
[laughter] 18th century,
19th century.
[laughter]
>> David Plylar: Well, I think
we actually need to get going
so that you can have
some time to get ready
for today maybe before we
go do we have time for one
or two questions from the audience?
>> Sandro Ivo Bartoli: Absolutely.
Yes. Yes. Shoot away
if you have questions.
>> We have a mic if, hang on.
>> Reading your read ahead last
night and I went to Wikipedia
to study the because I didn't know
much about Missoni and I was reading
about he came out with some theories
and semitone and I am wondering
if will we be hearing any of that?
>> Sandro Ivo Bartoli: No.
No. No. No.
No. It was called many times the
last renaissance man you know.
With many interests.
He painted.
He was an artist, composer,
great pianist, etc. It advised
for instance a new
system on notation.
A fantasy from Bach, grammatic
fantasy fugue in this new system
that he had invented
where the pianist played.
It was like a 20th century
version of [foreign name].
Of what they used to do [inaudible].
He got very fascinated with cartage
tones and he invented the scales
that I believe 115 pigmentation
but sometimes is intellectual
side was a little bit
over bearing to cover.
None of his innovation,
none of them took any hold
but if you are interested
there's a book that was published
in English called a Sketch
for a New Esthetic of Music.
First addition I think 1907 in
German and then got translated
in [inaudible] it's only about 70
pages but it's full of great ideas.
One of the most endearing to me is
that defending the
art of transcription.
He said that when a composer
actually writes down a piece
of music he is already
committing the act of transcribing,
an abstract idea into a
definite constricted medium.
So, that's maybe the best key to
approach the music of Senior Busoni
and also, we are lucky enough
we have some acoustic recording
of Busoni playing.
The small things but they are not
so small they are one of Lists
and Garner Rhapsody
I think is number 15
that give you a pretty good idea
of truly superhuman
capabilities as a musician.
>> David Plylar: Do we
have any other questions?
Well, why don't I, I wanted before
I finish here I just want also
to thank the Italian Cultural
Institute of Washington D.C.
for their support of
this concert as well.
We really appreciate that.
And if you can all just join me
in thanking Maestro
Bartoli for joining us.
>> Sandro Ivo Bartoli: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.